I am so probably sitting here at
basketball legend Dikembe Mutombo thank
you so much to Kim
that's where having me yeah listen yeah
what's your foundation
did you remember from this what is the
foundation yeah
Oh builder for the minute the hospital
my own money no way in the condo where I
come from does it feel good bad could
you fit in any of those beds do you have
a Dikembe ward finally how far do you
think you could he've me this is Chris
Berg I bet you could give me a good
heave uh I'm wondering about your shower
because I might the goal of my life I'd
like to show to be a success so I could
get a shower where the head is above me
everything is ah it's beautiful
Dumbo is awesome
hmm forgive me if you get this a lot I
would love to hear your full name cuz
it's not just a camera Mutombo became
uttama paloma comedy Ken Jong's on one
with Dumbo I want to put a beam to that
do it again you can move is there
anything more satisfying than making
Dikembe Mutombo laughs I haven't you got
a great voice I'm blown away by your
voice very different some people compare
me to the cookie master never get that
every day are you gonna punch me come on
Louie was a good singer he was yes
people did in my voice say I think to
myself what a wonderful world
wonderful
that's incredible would you say c is for
cookie c for cookie
[Laughter]
and then a couple quarters and a company
we don't pick my quarters or worse
so why basketball do you know what I
really didn't like basketball until I
was a sophomore in college is that when
they came in your room with a briefcase
full of cash
oh damn got the coach John Thompson you
will kill you ya know you remember the
look on your on your college coaches
face when he saw you oh you will smother
most kids of a certain age wanna be in
the NBA
what what would you tell these kids
3,000 young man finished college a year
only that 47 to 16 make today every year
even though you make a name yet they
ball would stop bouncing you still
always have to have something to move on
in life but the average Korean India
when I was like 12 years when you do
after four years you still you're about
16 more years to live in your life yeah
so if you have a good education less
diploma there's always that you can move
on you'll alive wait so which is worse
on the court getting crossed on getting
dunked on or getting your shot blocked
I think your uncle getting dunked on
yeah that's him I go don't you go well
you fall back on your butt and then
everybody knows oh you know far you got
your jump you don't you think you got it
and the guys was going to stop next time
you know who then you show your team I
do look they just walk away from you and
they don't ask you one up and they just
walk away it's good to be a good
defender but when you get
you know your teammates gonna kill you
yeah of course your voice sounds like
you froze on Solo in carbonite it's good
to be compared to so many people in my
life man hey cam you did this the finger
Wang don't move your hands only the
fingers the finger it's kind of like you
just got out of the shower noodles
around just kind of shake your hips
what's what's your big extravagance you
got something crazy in your house got a
heated toilet seat me I think Macbeth I
think are they giving the elevator house
elevator in the house there go from the
best men all over to you who for the
house that's cool I just want to say
thank you so much not for saying
something cheesy like my children or
something the elevator and wearables do
you need a woman a girl of ours you have
a guest house yes I will see you for
Thanksgiving just to make sure you call
first otherwise I would not open the
gate
I'll be like who and that's our time
with they came in a tumble man you are
incredibly cool thank you so much for
taking the time no no no I figured I'll
go left and one
[Applause]
[Music]